we're very worried deeply concerned
because this represents the biggest and
most disruptive period of industrial
action we've seen so far given that it
takes place over a four day period the
duration is significant but the timing
as well after a four-day bank holiday
when the NHS is obviously often very
very busy and the buildup of demand
coming into the Tuesday and in addition
to that of course the fact that many NHS
staff will themselves be spending time
with families taking leave after one of
the toughest Winters on record they
obviously need a well-deserved break so
that means in practice that the
challenges of this period are
significant add to that the fact that
Junior doctors represent around half of
all doctors in the NHS and there are no
derogations that's you know they there
will be emergency departments Critical
Care maternity neonatal Services
affected as well well that's going to
present a big Challenge and in addition
it's not just hospitals it's Community
Services mental health and so on okay
okay that one Chief exec One hospital
trust Chief exec says
um concerned doesn't even begin to
describe it what sort of scenarios are
you concerned about well we're concerned
about first of all the fact that again
we're having to see significant
postponements of patient treatment
because
staff will need to move from elective
areas where planned operations take
place to support the critical services
like the emergency department maternity
neonatal Services critical care and so
on and already in the last Junior
doctors strike we saw 175
000 patient appointments postponed that
was three days and not at this time this
time around we expect that to be more so
there'll be those patients that have
their care disrupted some of whom may
have been canceled
twice will also be seeing challenges
with some of those yeah you know a e
critical care and so on in terms of
Staffing given the fact that there are
likely to be fewer staff around to to
deal with those
um that filling the gaps that the junior
doctors will leave so that means that
I'm guessing quite a lot of regular
appointments will have to be postponed
or already being postponed yes I mean
patients if patients haven't heard
already that their appointment has been
postponed they should still attend
because many interests have been
preparing for this for some time
enormous preparations going into this
but there will be a lot of appointments
and planned operations that will have to
have been stood down in order to
prioritize the services over those four
days that are required for Urgent and
emergency treatment
doctors want a junior doctors want 35
pay rise
where are you going to land with this
well what we would ask is that
government and the BMA sit down as soon
as possible it's not too late even at
the 11th hour we can still avert next
week's action we saw what happened with
the nurses when there was dialogue and
the other staff side unions when the two
parties came together we saw an outcome
that materialized in terms of an offer
that's put to members we want the same
obviously to happen between the
government and 35 well that's obviously
a that's a starting point in
negotiations and all of this is about
the art of the possible in terms of
coming together key thing is they get in
a room together and try and thrash this
out because if not we can't sustain this
indefinitely what would you say to the
health secretary this morning well I I
I'd say to both sides come together try
and find a meeting of Mines try and find
a way through this because there's so
much at stake for the NHS right now at a
time when we're trying to reduce the
time that patients have waited the
backlog and the shock waves from covid
there's so much at stake we need all of
our staff together working to deliver
for patients out of time sir Julian um
Good Luck thank you I think you might
need it thanks very much Olivia for
joining us thank you